welcome back to CBS this morning
Saturday we begin this half-hour with an
invitation to a dance not a grand
society affair just an annual event in a
small town in Arkansas but as Jamie
yuccas reports it meant the world to one
little girl officer Nick Harvey gets
asked a lot of questions patrolling the
halls of Central Elementary but this
time he was about to do the asking I did
not want to be rejected by a second
grader what would that have been like
humiliating his boss had told him about
a volunteer opportunity to escort
children in need to the local annual
daddy-daughter dance
she was sitting at the lunch table and I
walked up and like hey it's like you
talked to your mom she's like yes and
I'm like I'm like so I said would you
like to be my date for the
daddy-daughter dance and she's like yes
I'm like we're good
eight year old av Cox's father passed
away over the holidays I've been when
they go for a long time my dad can't
take me Ava's mom Angela I mean I'm
truly grateful for it because he he
definitely provided a bright spot in our
in our crazy month we had before with
the help of her mom and a family friend
AV picked out the perfect dress and I
believe they went through about 10
dresses and the one that maybe wore was
I think the last one she had her heart
set on that one officer Harvey showed up
in his police cruiser they posed for
pictures
another officer ordered a limo to take
them to the dance had you ever been in
the limo before what was your favorite
part of the night can you dance with him
that made him smile were you happy you
got to go yeah would you go again do you
hope he asked you again you feel like
you can count on him but I couldn't
count on her too and his gesture may
already be having an impact so you want
to be a police officer mm-hmm why
because of Nick hmm what's the lesson
you learned out of this don't take
anything for granted
enjoy your kids I appreciate their
childhood because they're not gonna be
young forever for CBS this morning
Saturday Jeanne yuccas Van Buren
Arkansas I think that last one speaks to
all of us at this table I think yeah I
know my children are all grown up and I
sure wish I had been given that advice
sooner you still have them I know I'm
definitely does so I got mine late oh
okay